[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je vous
parlais de mon coup de coeur il s'agit
du film twenty one Jump Street de Phil
Lord et Chris Miller sorti en 2012 alors
il s'agit d'une adaptation de la série
du même nom des années 80 qui est
notamment à rendu célèbre un petit
acteur qui s'appelle Johnny Depp et donc
c'est l'histoire d'un Joe de policiers
un petit peu tête en l'air
casse-couilles qui se retrouve en
mission d'infiltration dans un lycée où
ils doivent découvrir un petit peu les
rouages d'un trafic de drogue dans ce
lycée les deux personnages sont
interprétés par Jonah Hill et Channing
Tatum qui forment vraiment un duo
comique incroyable cartoonk vraiment des
des fous rires à en pleurer tu veux bien
être mon cavalier au bal pour sortir la
poubelle non là on a pas le temps de
faire la bonus notamment aussi avec leur
chef qui est joué par le rappeur Ice
Cube voilà un petit caméo qui fait
vraiment plaisir très bon aussi très
rigolo c'est parce que vous des clones
de Justin Bieberon et de Miley Circus
que vous êtes ici le rythme est parfait
on est dans un dans un univers de lycée
totalement décalé et on a aussi en fond
quand même une belle histoire d'amitié
comment est-ce que des amitiés peuvent
se souder se dessouder par rapport à la
popularité tout ce monde du lycée qui
est au final il y a très cruel le lycée
avec avec les gens populaires et un
populaire voilà bref je vous conseille
ce film twenty one James Street de fill
Lord et Chris Miller
[Musique]